alrighty i am back i'm gonna be a little
bit behind schedule today just because
my roommate would not leave bed all day
and now i can finally record now that
he's gone so uh we're gonna talk about
search indexes which are a pretty
important part of any large-scale
company they pretty much all use them in
one sense or another so i'll talk about
the internals of those how they work and
then we can get through this video and
on to the next
alrighty search indexes what are they
well
a lot of companies have some sort of
search functionality embedded in their
application at one point or another i
mean if you're just taking google for
example it's pretty much their entire
business
amazon has the ability to search for pro
products based on a bunch of different
filters and you know you can do the same
on twitter for posts matching certain
keywords
but generally speaking databases aren't
great for these search functionalities
generally we want to use a different
type of data structure or
technology in general in order to
optimize for search functionality and
make it such that these very complex
queries can actually run really quickly
so what is leucine lucene is what's
known as a search index and it's
probably the most popular one it's been
around since 1999 and it's been open
sourced under the apache license
the actual search companies that people
tend to use which are you know
elasticsearch and solar
use leucine under the hood and as a
result of that i'm going to first
explain lucine and then i'll go into
elasticsearch and kind of how it builds
on that
so let's talk about the architecture of
lucian
generally speaking it uses an lsm tree
and ss table architecture and that's one
of the ways that it remains highly
performant so obviously first rights are
going to be sent to an in-memory buffer
the one difference here which is a
little bit nuanced for lucian is that
once the writes are sent to that buffer
you still can't read them just yet they
have to actually be propagated to the
disk first and in lucy and this tends to
happen once every second it's called
like a refresh period
so eventually the buffer is going to get
written to an immutable ss table index
file and then once there are a bunch of
ss table index files those are going to
get compacted and merged together which
is pretty typical for what we've seen
and then in terms of reads reads
actually have to be potentially sent to
multiple ss table files because each ss
table is kind of covering a different
set of documents and then once you get
the result of those reads you're going
to go ahead and merge them
okay so let's actually go ahead and
continue talking about this lucian
architecture because the ss table part
is only one aspect of it
so what actually happens when a document
is added to lucien well it has to be
tokenized which means that you're taking
all of the words or the terms in the
document and splitting them apart based
on some sort of rule typically you're
just splitting based on the white space
but then there are a few nuances as well
in terms of how we actually want to
handle the document because we don't
want to be mapping it to a bunch of
terms that don't really apply or that we
don't care about so obviously we have to
handle the punctuation
we have to handle you know the case of
words maybe it'd be better if we just
treated all words if they were lowercase
handling contractions such as like its
or their
you know with the apostrophe re and then
also handling common words like the or
and maybe we don't really care about
queries on these and we would rather
just filter them out
these are all also problems that occur
in natural language processing but just
tokenizing in general obviously you want
to be conscious of how you're actually
doing that because you want to be able
to search for these terms later and
you know if there are nuances within the
terms themselves you just have to think
about you know how am i actually going
to be tokenizing this document
okay so here's kind of the bread and
butter of a search index and this is
called an inverse index so inverse
indexes work by basically doing the
following once the document has been
tokenized we know that now it applies to
a list of terms so instead of mapping a
document id to a list of terms what we
actually do instead is take each term
and map it to a list of document ids
that contain it like i said this is
known as the inverted index and these
are what the ss table files are
generally containing
so that means that they're going to be
sorted by term by the way
but what if we want to just go beyond
looking at just one term itself and say
you know get all the terms with a prefix
of p e in this case
so let's start by finding all the
documents with those terms or at least
the terms that have that prefix and in
order to do so we can just run a binary
search on this sorted table and the way
you would probably do this is do two
binary searches where one gets the upper
bound so p-e-e in this case then one
gets the lower bound p-e-n
so you know that's how you would go
ahead and do that and that way we can
kind of find all the documents matching
this prefix in
login time
but generally speaking if we want to
just do searches that are more
complicated than just by term prefix we
have to add some additional logic and
here a couple of examples of that
what if we wanted to search by term
suffix so for example instead of
searching by p e we wanted to search for
all terms with e n
well what we could actually do here is
create a second modified index where
instead of storing the terms themselves
in the inverse index you store the
reversed characters of the term so that
way you can basically do the same prefix
searching logic but just with the suffix
and you go ahead and reverse that and
then run your binary search
another thing that's kind of similar is
doing this with numeric terms where you
actually look at kind of the the digits
of the number itself and that way you
can kind of say like oh you know like
let's look at the number 120 123
well they're kind of similar because
um there's actually or i don't know
maybe like
it's the fact that they basically have a
bunch of digits in common in the same
places and at the same start but i think
actually in reality lucian does use a
different data structure for things like
numbers and geospatial data so maybe
that's the topic for another video but
ultimately the whole point here is that
lucian can do a lot of really cool
search functionality and it's not just
on text but like i said numbers
you can do
text searching of similar words using
something called levenstein distance
which is you know done via some dynamic
programming algorithm and then also on
geolocation data which is a topic i will
cover in another video
okay so what is elasticsearch well
elasticsearch is basically taking
leucine and scaling it across a
multi-node cluster
so the way that we do this obviously is
going to be through some combination of
replication and partitioning
so we do have replication where each uh
thing that's being replicated is an
actual individual leucine index over a
bunch of documents
but also we have partitioning as well so
each index um you know can be sent to
certain nodes in the cluster and then
other index might be sent to different
nodes in the cluster and it's kind of in
this way that the data set is divided up
um so in that way elasticsearch
basically creates a bunch of local
inverted indexes keep in mind these are
not global inverted indexes it's not
like every single term or for a given
term we have every single document id of
it and then
that index is term partitioned but
rather it's document partitioned meaning
that
the index that's held on a given node is
only relevant for the documents on that
actual node so if you think about it
this has
you know obviously its advantages and
disadvantages it means that if you want
to search for terms across multiple
shards then you're actually going to
have to reach out to all of those shards
and merge together those results
but it also means that say we're you
know trying to implement a search
function on like a log functionality if
we put all of those log entries from the
same day on the same chart then we can
really quickly go ahead and make rights
to that shard and in addition to that
query it super easily
another huge benefit of elasticsearch
over just like plain old blue scene is
that it implements caching really well
and this is kind of how it achieves such
fast performance
so not only is there just like operating
system caching of index pages in memory
so if you think about it an ss table is
just a page on disk and um you know the
way that operating systems work is they
actually will tend to cache frequent
disk accesses so that way they can speed
up the actual you know accessing of the
index itself
but in addition to that elasticsearch
builds some functionality on top of that
where for a query on a given shard
basically it'll go ahead and cache the
result of that so you're not just
caching the index itself but say any
logic that you're doing with the index
or you know anything that you're adding
on top of that in the event that you're
going to end up doing that query again
and then furthermore
in addition to just caching the result
of the query um elasticsearch will
actually kind of cache components of
each query so that you know if a
separate query were to come along later
for a given shard and try and reuse some
of that data
then you know this could go ahead and be
really useful and you know if there are
parts of the queries that kind of
intersect
we already have that in our cache so
it's kind of in this sense that
elasticsearch is able to achieve really
high read throughput
okay ultimately search indexes are a
super important part of many large
applications
and it means that they can basically
find strings of text in a manner that's
much faster than just a traditional scan
over a database and kind of you know
using substring logic to try and find
the actual string itself
using ss tables in conjunction with an
inverted index turned out to be a really
good strategy for building a fast search
index and through
you know technologies such as
elasticsearch and solar
people have been able to go ahead and
scale out lucine in a manner such that
it works in a distributed environment
which is really great
also i'm really happy that i made this
video because i personally have looked
like a bozo in the past when bringing up
search indexes and then not knowing
about exactly how they were implemented
and then i felt like a real [__] so
hopefully you guys don't make the same
mistake and i will be seeing you guys in
the next one